our first presenter is himself a nominee
tonight you know once we let an actor
make us laugh we rarely let them make us
cry but he's done both so please welcome
the co-star Philadelphia and the world's
foremost piano key dancer mr. Tom Hanks
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you once upon a time all it took
to make a movie was an actor a camera
and a clear day those days are gone
today is mr. Miller vouchsafe earlier it
takes a few more days a few more folks
and someone to vote to provide more than
just a clear day and that someone is the
art director he sees that the background
is to quote an early movie review
panoramas of beauty that the actors keep
getting in the way of the nominees for
best achievement in art direction our
Addams Family Values art direction by
Ken Adam set decoration by Marvin March
the age of innocence art direction by
Dante Ferretti set decoration by Robert
J Franco Orlando art direction by Ben
vanoss and yon rolls the remains of the
day art direction by Luciana are a key
set decoration by Anne Whitaker
Schindler's List art direction by Alan
Starsky set decoration by Eva Braun and
the Oscar goes to
Alan Starsky for similars lists and for
set decoration II WA bran
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Thank You Academy Thank You Steven
Speilberg I would like to thank all my
friends who work with us in this movie
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
stay tuned for more Oscar excitement
with Marisa Tomei and Janet Jackson
[Music]